so we're here to talk about your new
show arrow but I can't start off with
our I've got to start off of course with
teamwork because you've got so many two
more funds out there of course and
obviously they miss you on the show what
was it like leaving it was it was you
know really heartbreaking I mean people
think that you know most the time when
people we've chosen to be for a bad
reason this was not for a bad reason at
all and um you know I I just I had to
take it well I wanted to be and you know
all the episodes and it didn't work out
that way so I had to take her you know
take a take a leap for myself and arrow
came along and then now I'm happier to
be on that show you know I still I the
other day we had a screening of team
will fit our creator Jeff Davis's house
and I still hang out with all them every
day and they're they're always moved my
family so that's all that matters to me
so was it like Selena's love scenes
well the here's the issue was is at the
time I didn't know that I wasn't going
back to the show so you know I they had
or two alternate endings where I either
died or I became a werewolf and they
picked the one way I became a werewolf
where I lived and then I ended up not
returning which was really sad but they
in in the storyline this year they said
Jackson is now the American Werewolf in
London so I'm in London right now yeah
weird you know knows maybe you know
maybe there's a camera here trying to
film Jackson there's you Columbus know
yeah Jackson is actually in London right
yeah you get to you know you have to
still I've loved for all the mall my
team of fans who have actually still
stayed with me you know through the
arrow through the arrow face so you know
they're still great they're still tweet
me all the time so yeah it's dead and
what's it been like shooting arrow your
pardon the pun compared the team well
you know it's it's completely different
it's it's you know Teen Wolf was a lot
about the relationships like winning
close relationships and also they've a
lot of special effects makeup with arrow
it's a lot of you know they they do
there are really great relationships but
there's it's a really massive scale you
know we have
cranes flying I mean at any point we
have so many cameras filming and they've
just got such a great budget and the
shows just had such a success and they
do to the comic book fans and you know
do 2dc that that we're able to do so
many things with with arrow and you know
we're able to shoot so many things that
some of it doesn't even make doesn't
even make it on the TV
so you never know what what you're gonna
be talking about you know when you're
doing press cuz you some of the fans
didn't actually get to see a lot of
things you've done in and which is
exciting because you know keeps you on
your toes
so definitely what were the things in
the last season that you thought that
didn't make it it would be great if it
had or wonder if it'll be on the DVD
well there was a lot of besides a lot of
the bloopers that come from me trying to
instead of you know do choreography
doing that the fight choreography it
looks like I'm actually in a boy band or
doing hip hop dancing which is not where
you're supposed to be doing when you're
trying to do a fight scene so it's like
me not quite understanding choreography
but I have as that and there's also um
there was a really really great scene
between a few great scenes between Thea
and I kind of explaining a little more
about a relationship and possibly
explaining things that we were going to
do together to help help save a few
people but I think they wanted to keep
it more of a mystery so they could drag
it out to the second season so that's
what's that's they're gonna be exciting
for the fans because they don't get to
see something that's been in the works
or you know at by the time the show
comes out at mid October is when the
second season comes out you know
something's been in the works for six
months so it's gonna be really exciting
and it's gonna be great to see their
reaction to those scenes yeah so will
you kind of be reliving moments that
were left out in that first season with
fear or taking things a different
direction or do you know yet how that
work I I do know that that within within
the very first episode you we find out
that there is a time jump of normal
times up so at that point ruin Thea's
relationship is you know really real
they're really in it and you know
obviously they're young so anything can
happen with young love but you know I've
watched TV shows where people stay
together for years on years and you know
gone through the hardships together for
five seasons but um I feel like
they're gonna be faced with a really
really hard decision based upon who
finds out if who unmasks the hood and
who who does it first so you never know
if your one asks the hood first Roy now
knows that the Thea's brother is the
vigilante you know so you know would he
keep that from her you know you never
know if she's gonna find out it's you
know it's gonna it could turn into a
triangle of really deadly my triangle
darkness in a way no yeah gosh don't
mean a secret oh there's gonna be a lot
of secrets and I have a feeling that you
know Emily Emily records character and
Felicity Smoak is going to UM I have a
feeling she because she obviously knows
everything that's going on with within
the group so um you know if people are
going to her for information she you
know she could be a big asset to helping
keep the identity secret for Oliver it's
a whole thing and really interesting
dynamic anything yeah it's it's there's
so many different things that they can
do and it's great because the first
season is obviously about introducing a
lot of characters and and things like
that which they've done really great job
at but now we disguise the limit with
what where they can go with everything
and who you think is you know actually a
good guy in a sense could actually just
be you know just trying to help the bad
guys out so mmm excitement hey and
mouthing I'm trying not to give
everything away
I've got there's gonna be I was know
because I was know if the interviews
that I don't give too much away the
executives like regular Lance here Marc
Guggenheim or Andrew Kreisberg they will
they'll retweet it or they'll tweet
about it so my god okay I still have a
job thank God
let's move a little bit away from
spoilers and let's move on to I know 15
will freeze up we had a very intense
fitness regime going didn't you and you
have been tweeting some kind of gym
shots like we haven't used well you're
still keeping that for air oh but how
does it compare for not you training in
a different way at all
I'm I'm definitely a different way for
Teen Wolf I put on 20 pounds which which
for me is I mean I've been a runner my
entire life and played tennis and things
like that and I'm naturally my whole
family's actually kind of small so um I
had Padma put our muscle was really
difficult cuz you have to you I mean
most people are like you have to eat all
day that's amazing but no like you
actually have to eat all day and you get
tired and you feel sick all the time
so now I'm gonna take I've been taking a
departure from that and I'm I think I'm
just putting on 10 pounds and doing it
not really using any supplements just
doing a healthy and just trying to stay
away from me you know cardio but just
having to do heavy weights and things
like that so I mean with training means
probably to be shirtless again and to
know it's just nerve-racking but you get
over it eventually so I have to keep up
with the Greek guy don't call him
Stephen Amell I just call him Greek god
his first name in Greek and it's his
night in Greek but he just looks like a
statue it never seems that you have to
do that you know it it's not it's funny
because it's like it's all smoke and
mirrors with with TV you know so like
everyone that has like romantic love
scenes and things like that it's you're
not just going at it
there are plate you know you have to be
placed the right way there's things you
like that so every when there seems like
that obviously you want to look your
best and you want to you want you know
the product to come out to you actually
then working hard at working out or you
just you know do a good angle and make
it look like you've been working out and
yeah you beg them to Photoshop in some
extra abs and then and then you might
feel like slip them a few 20s but I
would never do that
I wouldn't use a body bubble or anything
for for ab shots I've actually never
done that but now that I'm saying it can
I'd love to do that
so if I couldn't take a few days off
from the gym I would love if they could
just let me do that
I'm a used a body double for me for the
makeup on Teen Wolf because I was
the makeup so I think just find some
like really rip dude to like just do all
my services then I'd have the best job
in the world
maybe something to discreetly puts them
in your back well I need a clip out of
mine well other issue is I just signed
my contract so now I can't add things in
there I should have put must have sure
this body double on set who is a
supermodel yeah Susan three hopefully
they have the fans keep watching so they
can help me out with that we spoke on
the red carpet recently you tell me your
brother's a huge comic book fan so what
was his reaction when he found that you
were on a tour oh I I think the the
first first of all when he found out I
didn't tell I actually didn't tell
anybody because everyone you know my
family a lot of my family watched you
know Teen Wolf and my nephews do and
they were devastated because they you
know but my brother found out from a
comic book website the one he wasn't a
specific one every day I'm not quite
sure that's called and uh found out that
I was gonna be playing the role and I
thought something's wrong with I thought
so my nephew was hurt I thought
something was going on he was like
hysterical what is going on he's like
you're you're playing Roy Harper he's
literally like the Robin to the Batman
of the series and I was like I didn't
really know a lot about it what I went
into it didn't I didn't um it came out
of nowhere it was a one meeting and then
they gave me the role and I was like
okay now I know I look like the
character so now I have to figure a lot
more about the character and um the
thing that stuck with me was the fact
that I this is this will be the first
time where because I'm always playing
that the bad guy or things like that and
you know I am a little rough around the
edges kind of bad boy yes gonna show but
he's able to have a really big redeeming
quality and then kind of you know save
save a lot of people in aid to you know
people's lives so I was that's the one
thing that stuck with me I was really
excited about that
se not being a kind of comic book geek
wasn't anything he thought he said God
what was the strangest thing he told you
about that whole world healed is that
true can that be right
well he he told me that the fans you
know obviously he's it's fine I feel
like I'm being interviewed every day by
him which is so funny because I'm like
I've told you everything that I need you
know I'm I have to have him sign like an
NDA
not exposure so we cannot so we cannot
tell people what's happening but he just
said you know the fans are so invested
and you know you're gonna see a lot of
that and which I have seen a lot of that
the most unexpected people that I
wouldn't think you know I mean I thought
it was maybe a more teenage show but
it's not as a our demo demos a lot
higher so and now you know I have like
you know like so many different types of
people come up to me you know saying
that they really enjoy the comics and
that's great and so I'm just excited to
be a part of it it's one of the things
that you've told you about the comics in
green all right what would you really
love to say happen in the show at any
point I would love mmm you know it's
interested because with with it with
Emily's character she plays Felicity
Smoak of course she she blew everybody
away work from the beginning and that's
why they made her a series regular in
the first place and I it'd be
interesting because their chemistry her
not and Stevie Oliver's chemistry is
pretty electric it's really from right
from the get-go psych you know she's
fawning after him all the time and he's
flirting with her and everyone's wanting
I think they call it all olicity to work
out the shippers are saying all this
city okay that'd be nice to see but at
the same time you know if they get
together it's gonna ruin the whole you
know so that that would be fun to see
it's some sort of thing like that or to
see felicity Smoak's carrots or get a
romantic romantic involvement there's a
wait and see maybe Rory will meet you
know Felicity you never know I doubt it
because I guess I'm right now they only
team mean Thea are the only teenage you
know people on the show and I knew
Felicity months it might be like 25 so
technically that they're robbing the
cradle
so listen like Rob yeah that would be
really interesting well have to wait a
few seasons but yeah I actually don't
you think I'm 18 yet so technically be
illegal so Felicity cannot you know go
after Roy's so that's probably never
that and I've been a 10-plus fear would
probably be robbed so
if you could give boy any advice you can
give you a character provide any advice
the season two what would it be the
advice I give to Roy it's like I hope
you a washer hoody you know hopefully a
wash is your honey for you be I have a
guy would tell him I mean just to start
trusting people I think you know let
people in a bit I know they know he's
lived a long life of about not letting
buddy in and he has a reason to do that
but at the same time you know these
people are I think they're genuinely
cares about Roy and uh and I think you
know I know he teaching who cares about
her but right now it's looking like Roy
will do anything anything in his in his
you know anything possible to unmask
LaHood and to become a part of all of us
team and I do think that you know
possibly doing something to to harm Thea
could could come about by him trying to
do that so I don't know we'll see the
session is uh you know the Roy Harper's
like the kind of becoming a fan voice of
Oliver Queen but you really you don't
know if it's because he really wants to
work with Emily because he wants to uh
you know possibly betray him oh yeah
arrows hidden agendas semester we make a
little little extra yeah definitely with
my hip-hop good dog left my hip-hop
dancing yes this we would live to say
it's horrible it looks like a Becca
menacing video this is what my core I'm
he looks like my stunt choreography
you're gonna have any good believers on
the thief and T DVD you think it's funny
I saw I don't think they're gonna
release it which is unfortunate I'm
actually glad they're not gonna release
it cuz it's embarrassing they put
together a season one blooper reel and
just kind of you know we didn't know
about it they sent it to all of us and
you know you're laughing laughing it's
on your parts cover and a like they're
adding sight and sound effects and
making you look even
more like a loser than you already are
so you know I hope that doesn't come out
but you know season two I'm sure I'm
gonna be clumsy and fall and you know
that's that's always how it is so you
know we just you just live with it know
if you can see any characters from those
DC comics that your brothers told you
but come into either season two or
future seasons any point who would you
like to see it be interesting I keep I
keep saying Black Widow and it's not
Black Widow it's it's Lance's Laura
Lance's kept her character is supposed
to be this pivotal character that you
know could really come in and toss
things up and my brother keeps asking me
he keeps asking me you know it is and
them they'd be interesting to see that
also there's really you know there's me
some new characters I'm sure if you guys
have read there if they're going to be
joining and some very very well-known
characters that have been in you know
prior movies so I think it's gonna be
exciting to see that cast as those
people and you know or if they can get
it get some the people from the actual
movies to the played so how cool know ya
never know
anyways looking forward to that I just
wanted to come in and um it's funny
because I it's the one it's the ones
that I say are always the ones that
people start speculating so this is not
you know I obviously don't know I know
that there are a lot of popular ones
would it be nice to see passion it'll be
nice to see obviously they're almost
Superman or you know things like that's
come in but I don't know if that will
happen but uh I don't know maybe maybe
flash or like Green Lantern maybe you
know two greens yeah you know if I'm
sure you know Ryan Reynolds sees you
know it's not like he's a big movie star
or two things exactly I'm sure there's
so much down time you know yeah we'd
love that on the show we've people might
have to audition though yeah well this
is the thing isn't it
quano what someone's gonna be like to
you you never know so you know I mean if
Ryan is available and he's watching this
interview right now it's time for quick
auditions you know he's probably
following me on Twitter and you can
watch this
you can show it tape together and lend
it to you well just call Blake we'll get
her to talk to Ryan yeah sounds good to
me it's gonna happen I can see it happen
now obviously you saying before that you
pick up several months after that really
memorable season finale for season one
oh yes quite something wasn't it yeah
how is that gonna work do you think for
the show for fans like coming back in
and and what was it like filming on that
finale on that old watchman sad as well
it I didn't realize I had seen watch him
before and you know it was a big grin to
kind of you know the production and it
was actually I ain't gonna enjoy the
movie but I didn't realize that we were
going to have almost the same treatment
as they did it's they they've they
allotted so much time for us to shoot
the finale and we had such a great team
doing it that everything was preset when
we walked in and there were there were
five sets on five sets already pre set
up with other cameras so you know we had
cranes we had you know cameras attached
to cars and it was just this it actually
was really epic when we were doing it it
wasn't just done in posters actually
they made it feel like the destruction
was actually going down which was
amazing and I was actually like trying
to everybody's always funny because I'm
always it takes me a while to I always
had the bad luck where I'm running into
hit my mark and I was run into like one
of the extras running by or something so
that took a while because that happened
and that would probably make the globe
oil as well but um it was just the way
it turned out I didn't actually I saw a
few scenes from the finale I've not
watched it all the way through because I
I'm very upset with what happened when
at the end with the Tomas character but
um I choose just incredible so I I know
that by reading it it was incredible I'm
I haven't seen the final product but I
hear that it was just as good what do
you get to between techniques on sex I
read the own team look for examples a
lot of these double fake outs
oh yeah a lot of pranking it was oh gosh
if that was 50 was reality show
like move over Kardashians we would be a
nest even on daily lives like Holland
Roden she is the most special person I
think that I mean and I mean special and
like every single aspect of the word
I've never met someone so entertaining
than this girl I've even be reality show
that unlike any other but it's the same
with with arrow arrows you know we're
all arrow is so busy it's like
everyone's you know I mean Steven
doesn't every other day often even to
think about anything so he's just busy
busy busy which is great because it
really sets a great precedent for them
for the rest of us but for the ones that
you know kind of come in and out we tend
to cause a little trouble sometimes
but it's all in good fun what's the
what's the craziest thing that you
didn't say well on the set of air of the
craziest thing that I've done so far I
have you know so I actually the video
didn't turn out very good so I'm gonna
have to I'm gonna use some of the videos
but I'm netted together I uh
and you you obviously familiar with the
Ellen show Ellen DeGeneres she does uh
she does these dance dares where you
know someone will be having a serious
conversation and you walk up behind them
and you do like a really funny dance and
you edit it to whatever song you want to
I've done a few of those but I really
don't want to like has some people off
and add it on without telling them so I
might have to tell them before I put the
video or you know I could Ellen could
just you know have me on the show in
fact if they're gonna say that
we could you know we actually joked
about how if we Roy Harper was gonna
find his parents this year that we would
reach out to Ellen DeGeneres to to be my
mom I like you thinking I like you
thinking can you look quite similar same
features almost same haircut and then
you could do like another dance together
when you meet up you know I think she
played a great mother for Roy Harper you
retweeted something that someone said on
Twitter the other day someone had said
that your team was gonna start to
Holland should play Mary Jane in the
amazing spider-man Me's
we're not gonna have shining Woodleigh
and you know obviously retweets it so
I'm thinking you're got a big thumbs up
from you so why do you think Holland
would make a good MJ you know there's
some rumors going around that they're
there that they you know could possibly
going out all be going out Holland Roden
so do that which I don't know if it
would be replacing Mary Jane or if it
would be possibly playing another
character um but I think Colin I mean I
think Colin would have been an amazing
choice I also I think shaming Woodley is
absolutely incredible kids I've you know
obviously nothing against her I think
she's such a talented person and that
performance and and you know and the
last poem she had on descendants was I
was like I almost said divergent but
that doesn't come out yet um it was
incredible but um I think Holland is
just she really fits the role she really
Holland she's such an I mean she just
she needs to get more credit for things
she does you know you watch her on to
the orphans she's just got so much
emotional depth but she's such a such an
amazing actress and I could I literally
can see how in being like the next with
Reese Witherspoon she's she's got so
much character and she works really hard
for it so I I would love to see her do
that because it you know it did show the
rest of world vision with what she can
actually do yeah we've got lots of fun
questions for you and fans like Colin
Haynes don't work asked us to ask you
what do you like most about London and
England they're so they're so good to me
the people that run that site I I love
the thing I love most of anyone's is the
people the people are so you know so
culture is so nice and of course me yeah
and I sometimes maybe I can try to talk
like that I always go a little company I
think it might hunt even if I try to
talk like that because I'm a obviously
no I'm American so I I just think that
the people here are just so nice
no I think it's because it's you guys
are so happy that if you want to get
away from the cloudiness you can take a
$50 ryanair flight or train to Paris or
train anywhere you guys can be in
paradise so with us it's not quite the
same but you know I think everything
about London is just there's there's
like a electricity about the city you
know that's this is the people and
you've been at Wimbledon as well we know
why you've been here and somebody wanted
to ask you you said on Twitter that
you've met Downton Abbey's Michelle
Dockery and that she gave you all the
secrets they want to know what the
secrets worth is Phil Coulson sure I was
so embarrassed because I'm not the
person to walk up to someone and like
tell them I just act like I don't know
who they are Superman like oh my gosh
that's an ad Mary oh my gosh this is
closed so I was like in the corner and
my I opened my mouth and said that I was
a big fan of the Downton in' and they
dragged me over to her and i look like i
was a fan and it was even though i am
and it was she was very nice though she
um she she gave me I don't know if their
secrets and if they are secrets I have
to keep them the secret she ruined one
of the things for me because I didn't
finish the third season yet so she
started off by doing that for me and
then saying something else
and you think British people are so nice
easy yeah she's in it my favorite she'll
for me by dunno gosh
so in question what do you order at
Starbucks or whichever coffee Emporium
is your one of choice
I'm avid Starbucks fan which everyone
makes fun of me for that because there's
probably a lot you know there's so many
amazing coffee places out there but I I
get it every single day I get an iced
grande americano with half and half and
two splendas
and then sometimes I'm feeling of
interest I will get a venti and
sometimes I get the sausage and she's
something McMuffin that's McDonald's
well now they know I
the sausages cheese whatever muffins
thanks these yeah so yeah that's good
good to know
yeah I'm having Starbucks right now now
somebody wants to know what he liked
most about being famous I think with
being on a TV show you have ever to need
to kind of talk to people they you know
that you wouldn't have to talk to him to
people that follow me on my social media
which is great and also you get to let
people know that the things you do on
camera or not you you know I mean I'm
not I don't know I'm kind of obviously
like [ __ ] and crazy and you know
though is talkative and things like that
like the roles I played the paths are
just very blooming I do a lot of eyebrow
acting I kind of always in kind of
trying to be very sexy which is not me
in real life so it's it's it's nice to
with with you know I don't know really
whether it be Fame or just having you
know a following you get to you get to I
don't know kind of be a voice for some
people it's it's nice to kind of do I
hear from people from like the Midwest
cuz I'm gonna Kansas I hear from people
all the time saying that they have
dreams of doing what I do and you know
that if they whether they look up to me
for you know getting out of Midwest and
pursuing the dream that I've had my
whole life that's nice to hear because
she's long as you can talk to them and
say you know this isn't this isn't you
know magic it's you just you if you want
something you go after it and you keep
trying then you get it and then you know
then at least you have to try so that's
that's that with that you can do that
with Fame you can do that so let's get
Stephanie and I lift the eyebrow never
say you know just it's just I don't know
why that happens but I don't know people
always say that they're having like
caterpillars and they're gonna molt and
fly away in the butterflies somebody
else wanted to know what movie projects
have you got any movie projects coming
up and if not what would you like to do
ideally they're you know they're I don't
have any right now coming up there are a
few there are definitely a few
possibilities for me right now they
would have to be they would have to work
into a schedule but with you know with
the success of the show I've had some
opportunities to really you know take
some of the great meetings and
and get really close in a few projects
obviously the fulfillment it takes a lot
of time and I've been you know I've been
really close in a few projects with some
before but just hasn't been the right
time than you know so I am I hope that
some of these over are at least one of
these things pan out and then it works
out with a schedule so it'd be nice to
you know if it would be my first time
doing movies what movies and TV shows do
you like to watch me could be a downtime
you can't say t move or arrows okay
obviously Downton Abbey but I'm done
with that Michelle doc exactly she's
over on my list and she's on my actual
list like an arrow but I gotta love
shameless I actually I've only caught a
few of the the English version of the
show but I I got sucked into the
American version which is which is based
off of the show hearings I think it's
one of the most underrated series on
television so it's a really cuz it's a
gritty kind of amazing show than that
I'm obsessed with right now
and Breaking Bad is also incredible I'm
trying to get through the first season
right now but it's making it makes me
want to throw up sometimes so perhaps
like walk away but the acting is
incredible and well so I watch hmm I
always catch like if I'm flipping
through the sea like TV like the
channels I always catch the vapor gonna
have it here but I love HGTV which is
like love it or list it or like you know
the property brothers it's it's all
these shows about town like a real
estate than buying homes and you know
like things like that so I mean pretty
exciting stuff picking up advice behind
a vine house for the first time at the
beginning of the year and obviously I
would like it's my homes to look like
all of these nice places but I am I
wouldn't say I'm cheap I mean that's a
little too going a little too far I
would say it's frugal a better word it
was yeah
I'm cheap it's terrible but I would
rather you know I
rather save them then on some things I
definitely splurged on some things but
yes finally fun questions not like
favorite city in the world he been to
and where would you like to go that's a
hard one favorite city in the world I
can do top three okay London Berlin
Paris Portofino Italy oh I'm just gonna
have to stop it there and then where
else we'd like to go team milk vignette
I want to go to only what a Raziel I
want to go to Barcelona I want to go to
China so many places yeah I think I
think I'm gonna go to a few less places
fighting in a video so Masada
you